im Kino einen Film genießen ohne dabei
von Fremden gestört zu werden das werden
absoluter Traum deshalb habe ich in 24
Stunden mein eigenes Kino eröffnet
zunächst einmal braucht mir die richtige
ausstatt die typisch roten Kinosessel
die jeder kennt eine Popcornmaschine
eine naturmaschine eine Leinwand und
natürlich ein Beamer und nach kurzer
Recherche habe ich einen Verleih
gefunden der all diese Dinge im Angebot
hat ich danke tschüss let's go natürlich
brauchen wir aber noch einen Ort wo wir
das ganze aufbauen und hinstellen können
also haben wir kurzerhand unser Büro
leer geworden nachdem wir dann noch
schnell für Snacks und Getränke in die
Metro gefahren sind kam schon der
kinoverleih und wir konnten Anfang den
Raum komplett umzubauen fertig war also
nach 8 Stunden unser ganz eigenes Kind
kann noch schnell ein paar Leute
eingeladen das Popcorn fertig gemacht
und den Beamer gestartet natürlich
durfte die Werbung und auch die Langnese
Unterbrechung in der Werbung nicht
fehlen warum
[Musik]
sehr gut